ah Tom Holland hey everyone yes yes
butter man whoa
hey youtubers is Charlie so it looks
like spider-man homecoming really is
doing Mary Jane Watson or it might be
zendaya might secretly be that character
there's like a new rumor that's out so
I'm just going to explain there's a
couple contradictory things up until now
there's only been a couple characters
that have been confirmed there was this
Comic Con interview where John Watts
explains who each of the characters is
playing where he says that zendaya is
playing Michelle so he might be lying
but here I'll play it real quick so you
guys can hear it is Peter Parker like
that but you four we didn't get
identities from you today I didn't miss
it right because that's still under
wraps
oh well is that klonda huh oh you gotta
say he's like great so you're still seek
your identities are still hush-hush of
latched with Ned nothing is okay don't
get around those actually that's
actually really right so now obviously
you guys know that this is Flash
Thompson future venom space night the
character that this guy's playing goes
on to become Hobgoblin and if rumors are
to be believed then Sandhya is not
playing Michelle Gonzales who's also a
person from the spider-man comics also
one of his love interest but she's
playing the more classic character Mary
Jane Watson now this is already really
confusing because I totally believe that
they would be doing Mary Jane Watson
just because they want this movie to be
as big as possible and there's a lot of
awareness internationally for the Mary
Jane character nobody really knows who
Michelle Gonzalez's except for comic
book readers and that's only going to be
a small percentage of the people that's
going to see the movie so they just want
to have the biggest impact possible so
there are a number of different reasons
why Jon Watts could be saying that she's
Michelle here and then we find out that
she's actually Mary Jane Watson later
like a lot of times they will keep
things from the actors until they
absolutely need to know it but I would
assume that they've shot enough of the
movie now that zendaya would know
exactly who she's playing but if you did
see the comic-con trailer I did a
breakdown but I don't know if I
mentioned it
she actually has this really like ratty
looking hairdo she's really disheveled
they're I mean they're in high school so
she looks like your typical teenager
that just rolled out of bed in ran to
school so if you've seen any of the
other stuff that she's done she actually
pretty fabulous she looks like a model
but then you can imagine how they would
have Mary Jane Watson look kind of dumpy
in high school but then she grows up to
become this famous supermodel
so the Mary Jane that we would see in
the movie is like a typical teenager
somebody who doesn't look like they
spend four hours in a makeup chair every
single morning so in addition to a big
character like obviously Mary Jane
Watson will have a big character arc but
you'll see the ugly duckling grow up
into this beautiful Swan over the course
of the spider-man trilogy so let me know
in the comments do you think that
they're pulling a bait-and-switch she's
really going to be Mary Jane Watson and
how long do you think there's going to
be in the movie before she figures out
that Peter Parker is spider-man because
in that comic-con trailer she you know
she was running after him yell Peter
Parker where are you always sneaking off
to because he keeps having to sneak away
from school to be spider-man because
people need his help but because when
he's in the school he's a relatively on
lockdown he can't just leave anytime he
wants to so part of the fun of the movie
is probably going to be watching her put
the clues together like he keeps
sneaking off like what the hell's going
on what's that red costume thing
sticking out of the back of his backpack
but if it is true that zendaya is
playing Mary Jane then good job for her
it's gonna be a lot of fun I've seen so
many versions of spider-man that I
totally don't mind them changing a
couple things but if they are doing Mary
Jane a lot of you're like well does that
mean they're going to do Quinn Stacy
later well one of the reasons why I
don't think they're doing gwen stacy
right away is because they just did her
in the Andrew Garfield movies so they
want to give it a little bit of time
before the introducer back in same thing
with Green Goblin like they're not going
straight to Green Goblin right after
doing Green Goblin
so they'll get all the big stuff
eventually remember it's a trilogy so we
have six more years of Tom Hollands
spider-man at least and that's only
counting the spider-man solo films
that's not counting the other Avengers
crossover movies but in terms of actual
footage dropping I know that's the
question on everyone's mind like when
are we going to get the actual trailer
what I'm thinking is is because it's
going to be a summer 2017 movie is that
they'll wait for the Superbowl that
would be like the biggest event in the
United States at least in North America
where they could drop it but they might
drop a really small teaser in November
with Doctor Strange or in December with
rogue one with the Star Wars movie but
you know don't be surprised if
guardians of the galaxy and spider-man
trailers drop during the Superbowl like
really big trailers so get hype and
congratulations to this week's Marvel
will giveaway winner if you guys didn't
know they've been a Marvel giveaway
that's going on it goes on every week
David Harrison you win a $20 Amazon gift
card be sure to private message me on
the back end of my channel so I can get
your contact details there is a new
round of the Marvel giveaway that starts
now just because I'm so happy about all
that spider-man news so all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber and leave
a comment on this video there'll be a
whole bunch more DC Marvel stuff
dropping this week there's a Game of
Thrones video that I was going to do
that I just postponed for this so Game
of Thrones Season 7 is coming next why
you guys wait for that to post you can
click here for my breakdown to the
spider-man Homecoming Comic Con trailer
and you can click here for all my other
Comic Con trailer videos thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight
you